[Music]
mila kunis admits she and ashton kutcher
tried everything to keep their
relationship under wraps in the
beginning we were crazy neurotic about
keeping it secret
yeah probably a massive fault where we
alienated so many friends I'm sure right
the 34 year old actress opened up to Dax
Shepard on his podcast armchair experts
about the early days of their
relationship we didn't see each other
visually or I would say probably 10
years Wow I had a little bit of tequila
okay I was it was the Golden Globes
uh-huh and I was standing backstage in
this very tall very good-looking stature
of a man walk by but then he turns
around and I was like it was so like
what like I caught my selfie like why am
i checking out Mila revealed Ashton was
trying to set her up with one of his
friends before they initially hooked up
and when his buddy didn't show that was
the night that he and I hung out first
week and then you get a little tipsy
Noah's totally sober although the pair
did their fair share of kissing as an
on-screen couple on that 70s show Mila
says she felt major sparks with her
former co-star the very first kiss I'll
tell you this I while I was single never
spent the night at any guys house yes
this was the only time that I ever spent
the night at somebody's house something
else we learned about the sweet duo Mila
has a not-so-secret named for him while
visiting family in the Midwest I don't
know when we go to Iowa calm Chris oh
you do because that's what everyone
there calls him Chris right correct yes
so everybody has parents everybody calls
him Chris they try to keep doing it and
then I find he doesn't respond their
romance may not have blossomed until
more than a decade later but Ashton and
Mila are now married and have two kids
together three-year-old daughter Wyatt
and one-year-old son Dimitri but the
first and I would be like weepy
if this one I'm like it's fine
everyone's alive it's all good Mila also
got extremely candid about her ex
Macaulay Culkin whom she dated for eight
years in her early 20s like I told my
2000 can I'll be the first admit it and
that's kind of something that took me a
long time to come out and be like yeah
you know what I was a and I accepted and
I own it now
[Music]
[Applause]